so yeah I got this I got this article
from more from Wizards of the coast man
they're going nuts these people are so
they're they're basically making
Dungeons & Dragons
right they've declared it racist hold up
I do yeah yeah yeah pop it up right here
well I mean are we gonna talk about it
okay so this this is an article from
them from their dungeons and dragons
site talking about diversity and
Dungeons & Dragons dee dee dee dee dee
dee
yep it's the new the new version of it I
guess so I mean I guess I'll just read
it let's just see what it says it says
Dungeons & Dragons teaches that device
diversity is strength for only a diverse
group of adventure
adventurers can overcome the many
challenges a D&D story presents in that
spirit making D&D as welcoming and
inclusive as possible has moved to
forefront to the forefront of our
priorities over the last six years we'd
like to share with you what we've been
doing and what we plan to do in the
future to address legacy D&D content
that does not reflect who we are to who
we are today we recognize that doing
this isn't about getting to the place
where we can rest on our laurels but
continuing to head in the right
direction we feel that being transparent
about it is the best way to let our
community help us to continue to
calibrate our efforts okay so so Wow so
that was that was prepping us for the
rest are you reading it the orcs are
racist yes yes so yes you jumped ahead
and that's basically what I want to bury
the lead people are PI like why are we
getting this this this message well
that's why yeah it works I guess what
see and why I posted this earlier on on
Twitter and I was like they are making
the comparison they're making they're
racist they're making the yeah this
about race yeah orcs wert had nothing to
do with humans at all like I didn't I
never thought of an orca as a human like
they're orcs they're they're like an
eight not like an alien species but
basically if you were to think about
what another species is that isn't a
human being it's like it's like yes
please it's theirs it's riddled with
with here aureus they say we present
orcas and
DRO is it dresser oh I don't know in a
new light in two of our most recent
books ever on rising from the last war
and explorers guide to the wild Mount in
those books orcs and row are just as
morally and culturally complex as other
peoples we will continue that approach
in future books portraying all the
peoples of D&D in relatable ways and
making it clear that they are as free as
humans to decide who they are and what
they do did what what what that's
condescending I don't understand why our
orcs racist this mythology it's like
there is actually an old idea because
this is actually from Lord of the Rings
and this stretches back a few years and
what's really interesting about the Lord
of the Rings is that there are actually
multi-ethnic different kinds of races in
the Lord of the Rings universe right
works they honed in on and they're like
this is what remind us of black people
right really pointing right so they're
saying that the humans represented in
Dungeons & Dragons can't be black there
isn't black adventurers like what bro
why I figured it out what why why not
why is that not is such a far-fetched
idea for you think Wizards I figured it
out just right now oh do tell right now
tell us Tim breaking news everyone Tim
figured it out aliens hey no no I'm
serious okay I'm 100% see it out you
need a beanie with the fuzzy hair it's
just clever on my brain uh-huh cuz my
brain goes quick and you know it I was
thinking to myself as you're telling
you're talking about this mm-hmm I'm
thinking like we just have these
depictions of monsters to give us
something to fight against orcs are not
people on purpose so that we can create
a villain that we fight against that's
exactly work emerges and we're like it's
not a human and we stand side by side
with our human brothers and sisters
right to fight the not humans yeah why
hold on why would they need to convince
us that non-human creatures are just as
diverse and culturally you know what do
they say culturally complex as we are
excuse me Tim work lives matter no
listen this is important wait hold on
it's because when the aliens come
all right they're gonna tell us not to
be specious oh so so so I am kidding by
the way but but but like the the general
idea is in Lord of the Rings there's
actually you know different races
there's there's white people there's
black people right apparently I'm not a
big Lord of the Rings person but I was
reading in the books yeah I was reading
about I was like a southern continent I
guess yeah and the orcs were literally
not humans right that's part of the
point yes and so in a lot of stories I'm
thinking so what's next are we gonna be
like you know what's what's the Balrog
is that the name of that demon the big
huge the big demon it's like Balrog
light fire whip yes look clearly pretty
cool it is a whip right very cool I
think it was a whip then it's
intelligent and it crafted a large
weapon for itself
there's slavery locations there yeah
yeah so how come how come how come
Gandalf went went listen when he walked
up the Balrog did he say we come in
peace
no no he said you shall not pass
gatekeeping and then said girl a quiet
wizard and then did racist no nothing
that he destroyed he destroyed the
bridge saying you're not welcome on our
side and he became a white wizard that's
right oh man cancel Lord of the Rings no
no but in all seriousness come on
there's an interesting idea there and
that we create monsters so that we can
have a challenge yeah that's what works
are we don't just want to fight a dragon
that's mindless yeah we want so we so in
for instance unlike Magic the Gathering
anagen and and dungeon to dragons yeah
you have super intelligent all-powerful
dragon beings that can shape-shift and
things like that are we now gonna are
they gonna come out and be like actually
the dragons are intelligent and we just
need to negotiate with them okay I got I
got an idea let's get rid of the
dungeons we can keep the dragons though
okay because dragons their lives matter
whoa whoa but there's different colored
dragons though Tim so when we get into
that or get into that part of it though
no but listen we should call the game
diversity and Dragons but it feels and
we got to get rid of the weapons no
weapon the magic should all be healing
well words words hurt nowadays so sure
weapons will just be words okay a point
right and yeah and the goal will be to
well no it's it's the
the bad guys try to hurt your feelings
oh by calling you names okay oh yeah
okay and they're fascists okay yeah
perfect so you team up with the Dragons
and the bad guys are white people okay
because that's not racist well it feels
like that's what they want how about
this
the orcs are not the good guys the white
people are the bad guys okay will that
make them happy though I think that
would actually be socially acceptable to
be honest yeah might be yeah we should
try no but I mean I mean I mean I'm kind
of joking but think about it seriously
if they're like oh don't don't rag on
the orcs they're culturally complex it's
like okay well then I don't know we can
recommend my people right because that's
what they do all day and night you know
they complain about how they're
inherently racist so then you make the
bad guys the racists and then the game
is about you being an orc and a dragon
teaming up to take down the fascists
diversity and Dragons there you go we
should stream the game the D and D tag
yes it's perfect and all all of the dye
you have are they're all there it's a
d20 but it's every site is 20 and then
he's all 20s and then can you roll for
hit please 20 Wow natural 20 good for
you and so by the way we have
participation trophy any time you hit a
20 you so so so here's what happens the
bet that when you when you roll for
though for them for the bad guys for the
fascists okay there's are all ones right
so here's what happens
but remember words are found like a fun
game
words are violence so when you encounter
the the fascist and he calls you naughty
words okay that hurts but you roll for
defense and because you have critical
race theory training you roll a natural
20 internal memory but then when you
roll to attack using your words you
calmly explained to him as white
privilege and the fascist converts and
then joins your party oh there you go
yeah yeah and they you know but they
they have to like you know kiss your
boots okay diversity and dragons yes
that was I can't even start here D&D man
they they did it Wizards started it by
banning some cards we talked about a
couple times already
I got a theory and they're just
continuing continuing on I got it I got
a theory man the people who are doing
this are legit white supremacists yep I
don't I'm not you think it
but hold on let's let's let's actually
break this down where are the white
supremacists right now I have no idea
they're not doing anything right are
they are they doing press conferences
are they coming out and saying like
here's a list no they're not so what are
they doing where are they they're
probably watching us all go down and I
don't know hold on hold on laughing I've
known or they realized that the actual
path to getting what they want is to
pretend to be on the Left hmm yeah okay
maybe think about what's going on right
now it does feel like they're trying to
make it right orcs they're trying to
come like divide everybody orcs are not
minorities orcs are not human being
they're not exactly so one of these
people came out and made a comparison
and the whole left went yep yep that
we're growing stars they're just
fictional creatures that we fight as
villains Damini
now think about what's going on with the
removal of these these these characters
now we can talk about Aunt Jemima
because of her history as a character
from a minstrel show but Uncle Ben
literally just a farmer right literally
just a farmer and they said get rid of
him so the the black icons of these
these old-time you know a brands is are
being purged mrs. Butterworth's did you
hear this no new one they want it they
want to change the mrs. Butterworth's
because guess what the bottle of mrs.
Butterworth's corn syrup not good by the
way I get that real Vermont stuff yeah
take it from stick sex and Hammer okay
okay the bottle is a shape of a woman
okay
it's supposed to be regular oh grandma
uh-huh but maple syrup is brown okay so
people started complaining that it was a
brown or black woman so they said
they're gonna be addressing the the
imagery they use in their brand white so
you do of status' being torn down to be
honest right and the Confederates are
being torn down must be real but I have
to wonder why it is they're removing why
they're comparing orcs to minorities and
why they're removing Uncle Ben mrs.
Butterworth's
well who benefits from all of this who
benefits from segregation that's that's
the supremacist I don't I don't want to
cite white supremacist yes supremacists
in general look at South Side's it
doesn't matter where you are if your
supremacist you want division amongst
the population
you saw what Terry Crews said yeah
exactly those at first I haven't seen at
Terry Crews great actor very funny guy
he said right he's seen it he said if we
he said if we want to end white
supremacy we have to do with white
people otherwise we get black supremacy
right he got a war up he but he stuck to
his guns need an interview yeah where he
said he's I believe his wife is
mixed-race okay and he was like and he
gets attacked for it he gets called all
the racial slurs and in the world for
being successful and he's like we can't
have this we got to be equals we got to
be together yeah and I'm like right on
brother
this dude's amazing yeah the fact that
he didn't back down he went out in an
interview and explained what black
supremacy was I was like wow I was
impressed yeah yeah that's brave yeah
but you know what he gets it because his
wife gets its attacked this man I can I
can only imagine what it must be like
for someone like Terry Crews to be
successful you know and to be trying to
make a better world for his family for a
wife who's mixed-race and then to get
get attacked from both sides but here's
a thing both sides I'm not talking about
regular Americans yep cuz you know
regular extremists exactly and the
extreme and and it's not dude I'm
telling you the extreme right doesn't do
anything sit back and wait or no they
just talk they just make youtube videos
yeah the left is going out with
pitchforks and torches yeah and and the
extreme right is like showing up to like
meetings and try to have conversations
with people right and they don't want to
have conversations they just want to
screech and shove it down your throat
but the left is it works for them like
they're getting stuff done man look at
all of the hard changes but that's
that's the question I have and that's
why people say that the left is their
white supremacist with guilty
consciences yeah because it's it's not
us regular liberals who immediately look
at an orc and think mmm that reminds me
of a minority group yeah no never
right it's the left that said the
goblins in Harry Potter we're Jewish
it's it was the left that said orcs
where am I you know minorities what
that's true it wasn't Junior Tolkien
apparently was like a staunch
anti-racist of course and and orcs
didn't represent minority groups they
didn't represent human beings at all
right I read this really big thing about
like someone some like a super super
Tolkien fan who got really offended by
the left's claim about racism or
whatever okay and they broke down like
Tolkien's history and like his personal
views yeah
and they went through the lore and they
were like how dare you yeah like Lord of
the Rings you know there's some diehard
Lord of the Rings fans out there for
sure they're they're legitimate fans and
now Dungeons & Dragons man what were
they doing this they're gonna they're
doing a bunch of other things I don't
know it's just so dumb it is and you
know what all that I did a tweet earlier
and we're reading all the comments
everyone was like we don't care what
they say we make our own stories anyway
and if you're not doing that you're not
playing it right right that sounds right
if you're gonna play Dungeons & Dragons
Do It Yourself
make make up your own story that's
that's how I played it with my friends
it's so on that way so why do we need
them to come out and tell us what works
are you don't it's called virtue
signaling yep right that's what it is
there's a Turing to the masses right now
the masses that they think are the
majority because they're the ones out
there screaming the lowest that's true
thanks for checking out this clip from
the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the show
live Monday through Friday at 8 p.m. if
you want to catch the full show tune in
to this channel subscribe hit the like
button or check us out on iTunes and
Spotify and we will soon have this
podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you